Jake juste à temps,
mademoiselle Peregrine est ravie de vous rencontrer,
mon grand-père m'a parlé de cette maison
pour enfants particuliers.
est le décor en Belgique,
il est dit verboten mais nous pouvons entrer
ici c'est Castille Turin HOF qui ressemble tellement
à ce que j'avais imaginé regardez
cette belle propriété c'est fantastique
Tim a pris les idées que j'avais et les a rendues
plus grandes et dynamiques et a créé un  monde dans lequel
vous pouvez vous perdre il est une
oie invisible est des animaux topiaires avec lesquels jouer non
je ne vais rien casser je ne peux pas être
tenu responsable 51 secondes de retard désolé
mademoiselle Peregrine l'une des choses amusantes à
propos de cet ensemble est le jardin de Fiona elle
cultive de la nourriture  comme des carottes de dix pieds de long
ressemble à un repas particulier hé je
joins elle est gênée devant
Jake ne soyez pas le terrain de
la maison de Miss Peregrine sont les enfants du
monde entier ils quittent la maison ils seraient
mangé vivant par bonjour halète OH
et tellement cool de regarder tout prendre
vie et j'aime la façon dont le timbre et les
équilibres jouent avec le noir comment
allez-vous j'ai juste hâte de voir ce qu'il
crée probablement une chose que je promets de
venir avec moi
il y a un endroit où je vais quand je veux être
seul comment as-tu
mes particularités si je te montre le reste
tu dois promettre de ne pas t'enfuir
j'aimerais le livre de Branson j'aime le fait
qu'il ait fait une histoire à partir de ces vieilles
photos  Je me sentais juste très convaincant
et mystérieux il est invisible qui est
où ce qu'on appelle dans le langage courant
le coréen quand j'ai entendu dire que Tim Burton
allait faire le film j'étais comme
quoi c'est fou
je joue à miss Peregrine elle dirige la
maison les enfants particuliers ils vont  dans la
clandestinité parce qu'ils sont chassés, leur propre
vie est menacée et ils doivent
trouver un moyen de sortir de ces situations en
utilisant ces particularités parce que nos
capacités ne correspondent pas au monde extérieur
nous vivons dans des endroits comme celui-ci tout
r  ely se réunit comme un
film de Tim Burton son enthousiasme est contagieux
Je vous assure que nous arrivons de grands
personnages ont une vision et c'est ce que les
acteurs adorent il y a quelque chose d'
assez poétique et de beau dans ce
monde entier c'est rafraîchissant qu'un film
dise embrasser votre unicité don  n'en ai pas
honte je savais que tu étais l'un d'entre nous
quand tu es né il est temps pour toi d'
apprendre ce que tu peux faire
toi